and uh
at three times I guess we have a coffee
break
I'm happy to introduce Alex demo and it
is a senior researcher at the Google
train in
[Music]
um
stability
everything is beyond just a
predictability of machine learning
and you say
famous for his welcome
Sports
and yeah we're curious to hear what you
have to tell us about
um
talk is actually all about basketball
great
um yeah I I will uh
isn't it that this is a sort of uh
talk that that comes out of my trying to
make sense of uh you know what what it
is that we're trying to do when we uh
interpret models post talk
um and I am focusing because this is the
you know looking at interpretable
machine learning and natural and social
sciences on the science aspect here so
specifically thinking about the version
of interpretability where we think about
trying to interpret a model in order to
learn something about the world
um so a little bit about me uh so I'm
I'm at Google research on on the brain
team there uh my sub team focuses on
causal inference
um but I sort of sit within a broader
group uh whose main focus is deep
learning
um and so this has really shaped my
perspective a lot the stuff that uh I my
team work on is uh has to do with uh
making causality machine learning work
well together whether that's making
machine learning better through causal
ideas or using machine learning to do
better causal inference
um and the way that I've uh that I I
tend to think about how we end up
approaching problems uh it was actually
very much shaped by uh this sort of
famous Leo Browning paper statistical
modeling the two cultures uh I think the
vast majority of my talks start uh this
shout out to to this paper uh for those
who aren't familiar with it um this was
one of the papers that tried to send a
shot across the bow to the statistics
Community about how machine learning is
really a thing that we should be paying
attention to
right this was a paper in 2001 a
discussion paper in statistical science
where uh Brandon makes this argument
that in a lot of problems what we're
trying to do is we're thinking about
nature as this sort of black box where
inputs go in outputs come out and right
what we uh there are different ways that
we try to sort of model this black box
right and at the time he was saying in
statistics the uh dominant culture was
one that tried to do data modeling where
you actually write down a set of models
um right that you can sort of keep in
your head and write down by hand
for how these X's are mapped to y's
right so you're sort of modeling the
inside of the black box and he was
suggesting that we should at least pay
more attention to this algorithmic
culture where instead of trying to
specify what's inside the Black Box you
just try to emulate these relationships
between inputs and outputs using
something that is itself a little bit
more black boxy
right and so I think since 2001 uh the
algorithmic culture has really picked up
right to say the least right it now I
think runs a huge number of services
that impact all of our lives
um right and uh one of the key points
that bryman was making in his paper was
that um the way that you can sort of
hold this entire Black Box thing
together is to think about these held
out evaluations right predictive
performance on held out test data
um so in machine Learning Land a lot of
people call these IID evaluations uh
statisticians I think tend to cringe a
little bit when we say IID valuations
but what I mean here is that we think
about having
some training or validation set where we
actually train a model and then at the
end of the day we're going to take
predictions on some held out test set
where this test set is constructed to be
identically distributed to your training
or validation stack
okay so this is I think when most people
talk about predictive performance this
is sort of what they're thinking about
and this has really been machine
learning secret socks right so if we
think about uh the way that machine
learning works today it is not too
unlike this prophetic XKCD from several
years ago right that uh it's sort of a
big pile of linear algebra and uh you
know you poke it in different ways you
tune the right hyper parameters and
eventually the answer is coming out look
pretty good
um right and so this is actually very
similar I think to Leo bryman's sort of
vision for uh the algorithmic modeling
culture
now at the same time if we want to do
science with these kinds of models right
I think there's still this desire to go
back to the data modeling culture right
and I think that's because it really
sort of fits more naturally into the way
that we tend to think about the
scientific method I'm sorry I'm not a
philosopher of science so um you know
for those of you who are uh I appreciate
your patience right but at least you
know in my grade school understanding of
the scientific method right we're trying
to do is articulate some general
theories right and then test specific
predictions on data right and then
um while the theory survives we're happy
to sort of work with it as long as it
makes good predictions but eventually
right we may reject it in at least in
circumstances where it doesn't predict
very well
um and so I think the data modeling
modeling culture really comes from this
tradition of specifying a theory right
sort of a full theory that you can hold
in your head
right and then uh try to refine the
internals of that black box
um until it actually predicts well
right
but I think in in a lot of different
fields we ended up sort of hitting a
wall right where the parametric models
that we could specify were never
actually predicting that well right and
what ended up happening was that the
algorithmic modeling culture came in and
said hey why don't I just try a black
box model to do something like modeling
protein sequences right and suddenly
there's the step change right in in the
performance in the predictive
performance of models right and so when
that kind of Step change happens then
you can sort of think about turning this
data modeling uh pipeline backwards
right instead of thinking about
specifying a theory first maybe what
you'll do is find a black box that
predicts really well first and then try
to back the theory out afterwards
right and so I think this is to me
having having read some of the
interpretability literature it feels
very much like some of the uh motivation
for trying to interpret Black Box models
after we have fit them right and
certainly in the discussion of this
paper
there is a lot of discussion about
trying to extract information or uh
something post hoc after we have uh fit
the model right so through ideas like
various variable importance or other
heuristics
okay and so I'm going to be focusing on
on this particular uh approach and I
think actually causal inference
um at least the modern version of causal
inference that we have now also sort of
fits pretty nicely into this particular
approach right where we first find some
predictive models we try to predict the
observables that we have as well as
possible
and after the fact we then process those
to pull out scientifically meaningful
quantities
so if we think about the advantages and
challenges of algorithmic science right
I mean the the sort of clear Advantage
here right is that I we can pass our
predictive checks right just sort of by
definition because we've specified our
models based on whether or not they
actually pass the predictive check right
so this has been a stumbling block
before so that's great that we can sort
of get the prediction part out of the
way
but at the same time right there are
major challenges here about the fact
that prediction is often not sufficient
to identify a single single emulator of
nature right so what that means is that
if we can't be sure that the thing that
has solved our predictive problem also
has similar internals right to the
Natural system that we're trying to
model then we don't really know whether
the interpretation that we construct of
that black box is actually going to
correspond to some naturally interesting
quantity right
and so to me this is the identification
problem in causal endurance right that
there's some sort of mechanism that we
would like to pull out of the data that
we're modeling
um and there's a question about whether
we can actually identify that mechanism
right whether there's a sort of unique
inverse from The observed data uh that's
going to tell us about this naturally uh
or this this aspect of nature that we're
actually interested in
okay so
um I'm going to sort of argue that a lot
of modern modern causal inference is
essentially an interpretation method
right and in fact what we're doing is we
are ascribing causal interpretations to
summaries of data and models
right and the way that we do that the
way that we sort of approach the uh
identification problem is to articulate
assumptions outside of the data model
and try to design our studies to satisfy
these assumptions right so I think this
is sort of a recurring theme here that
in order to uh have meaningful
interpretations of a model the
interpretations need to be contextual
right and so this is sort of how we end
up specifying the context of a causal
model right so usually these sorts of
assumptions are rolled into something
like a causal model that defines
populations interventions how variables
are going to respond to interventions
and then uh you know what is observed
and how comprehensively we observe those
things
so I think one of the sort of overriding
questions
that I'd like to bring up with this talk
is to see if there are corresponding
Notions in scientific applications of
interpretability now
right and maybe for for those folks who
are actually working in scientific
applications uh if it's possible to sort
of draw connections between the core
assumptions that we make when we do like
causal inference in the statistical
community and the key identifying
assumptions that you feel sort of
justify interpreting a model of a
natural system
right so I'll try to make that that was
a little bit abstract I'll try to make
that a little bit more concrete with uh
some cartoons here
right so when we're doing causal
inference right we have some set of
causes a
um this could be like a very complex set
of causes right that are producing some
kind of outcome why
and the thing that we're interested in
right uh these causes again can be sort
of complex right the thing that we're
interested in is uh right what happens
sorry I'm gonna
when we intervene on these causes a
right so this is a distinct thing from
what happens when we just observe what
happens when a happens to take these
values right uh we can sort of say that
the conditional probability of Y given a
is the values of Y that we tend to
observe when a actually takes a
particular set of values but here we're
interested in what happens when we
actually set
these values at a particular place right
so we're thinking about our model here
as being an emulator of nature where we
can change the inputs and then it is
going to produce the outputs that nature
would have produced for us
all right but we all know that uh the
correlation and causation are not the
same thing right and one of the main
reasons for that is that right if we
were just to model the sort of
relationship between a and Y they're
often common causes right that are also
going to cause and Y to change together
and these are things that we can't
really tell apart
right uh just by looking at the
relationship between a and Y
and so right what we have from our
observed data is something like this
conditional distribution
what we'd like to be able to observe is
what would happen in a world where
there's no backdoor path from the causes
to the outcome right
and so like a big part of causal
inference is really trying to solve
what's essentially a domain adaptation
problem Right Where You observe data
that's generated under one generating
process you'd like to be able to make
predictions under a different generating
process
and so how do we go about sort of making
this jump
well in uh in causal modeling like in a
lot of modern causal inference what we
end up doing is fitting some models to
observable quantities right these are
the relationships between y a and X or
the relationships between a and X right
and then we end up
plugging these into some summary so
there are many different summaries that
we can sort of plug in these predictions
into
to then obtain what we think are
meaningful quantities of causal effects
or meaningful quantities that that
correspond to uh how we think this
outcome would actually respond to
intervening and setting these cause
variables to take particular values
right so this is sort of my like
Whirlwind summary of how uh we could
think about the way that model modern
causal inference is done right now as uh
as essentially a way of interpreting a
couple of models that we have for
um observed data
or the two
creation is visible oh yeah yeah sure um
so it's possible for us to talk about
the question was whether I can comment
on whether in the physical world this
new operation here is actually feasible
so we're called the do operation means
that I reach in and I set a particular
set of values uh particular that I set
the causes to take a particular set of
values
um and in some cases the do operation is
feasible
um and in some cases it isn't right so
um
right in cases where uh it's feasible
you could imagine something like a uh in
a genomics application where you're able
to do knockout experiments right uh you
can actually potentially set this Vector
of causes to something that you want
although there may be some error in in
that particular sort of uh
implementation right if you're thinking
about something like a computer system
right then you sort of have full control
over the system so you may be able to
say that these are flags that you're
sort of passing into the command line or
something
um yeah but uh in principle
uh you can Define these causal
quantities
um in terms of a sort of well-defined
intervention
um right but I right I think there are
there's been a lot of ink spilled about
sort of how feasible these uh
interventions need to be right and uh
whether we think that the particular
intervention that ends up setting these
causes to a particular value
is uh uh is actually sort of a a
well-defined singular action okay and so
like some of the core assumptions that
we have in causal inference are about uh
like making sure that we're all on the
same page about what the intervention is
I think it's a it's a nice question
anything else here
okay all right so one thing that I the
the main reason that I wanted to
introduce all the causal formalism here
is just to sort of provide some concrete
examples of
uh ways that relying on predictive
performance alone is not enough to
ensure that the model that you're going
to interpret actually contains the
causal mechanisms that you would like to
pull out about the natural world
um so one of the primary things that I
think sort of prevents us from trusting
models that are calibrated on prediction
alone right are something that Brian
himself in in the 2001 paper called
rashimon effects right so uh for those
of you who aren't familiar rashimon is
this uh classic japanese movie about a
set of events that happen in in a forest
and the different Witnesses of that
event each tell their own story of what
happened right and they all tell very
different stories of the exact same set
of events
and so similarly we can think about the
same set of data right and uh fitting
multiple different models that all fit
the same set of data equivalently right
and in those cases it's very difficult
based on predictive performance to tell
which one of these models is better
right each of the models tells a
different story about
um in in this case right Brian was
thinking about which variables are
important but you can also think about
it as each model tells a different story
about what the mechanisms of nature are
which is better I mean it was way better
I mean do you really believe that there
is some ground truth nature that maybe
there isn't about translation maybe or
we care about this prediction
technology
well I I can I can repeat the question
right now so the question is whether
whether I believe that there's actually
a ground truth nature uh and you know
whether maybe everything that we
actually care about is is just
prediction
um and so yeah I would say that this is
uh
I don't think that we necessarily need
to get down to claiming that there's a
ground truth in nature but I think that
uh there are more stable mechanisms
right that sort of transfer across
different settings uh then uh
then the like candidate mechanisms that
end up coming out of models that we that
end up fitting just a particular uh data
set very well let me let me give you
some examples right here and then uh we
can come back to it
um so one I one instance of this that's
very near and dear to my heart is
something that uh a group of us at
Google called under specification so we
say that a machine learning pipeline
right this is a pipeline where you train
a model that is uh like trained and
validated on data I and then tested on
data that it has the same distribution
as what you train and validated on uh we
call this
image this sort of standard machine
learning pipeline right we say that this
pipeline is under specified if there are
many different models that you can pull
out of this pipeline that share most of
their specification
right but end up being distinct from
each other right and so for example in
in this particular paper what we did was
we looked at a bunch of different models
that were trained on exactly the same
data right using exactly the same
architecture the only thing that
differed between them was the random
seed that we used at the beginning of
training right and at the end of the day
we ended up producing several different
models that were that that operated
substantially differently in terms of
how they emulated patterns in the data
right so one example of this we looked
at natural language processing models
right something that we're often
concerned about in natural language
processing models is what signals are
being used to solve different problems
that we're trying to solve in text right
and in particular we may be concerned
with how much the model relies on gender
cues in in text right
um so for example here we have we have
the sentence where there's a pronoun in
the sentence and it's unclear
whether this pronoun uh corresponds to
the patient or to the nurse right and if
this model is relying on gendered
signals right
um I mean from Context you can sort of
tell that it's probably talking about
the nurse since this is the person who's
actually working in this sentence
right but if this model relied too much
on gender cues
and in particular it was aware that
there's a correlation between gender and
being a nurse it might actually make a
mistake
right and so this was something that we
were interested in
um and so what we did was uh we set up
this test right where we took a bunch of
different models again trained in
exactly the same way using the same
architecture on the same data sorry
um and we train these models to uh solve
a semantic similarity task so this is a
task where you give the model two
different sentences and you give it a
score that people gave about how similar
these sentences are right and you just
ask the model to sort of emulate the way
that people score the similarity of
sentences right
and in this particular stress test what
we did was we then asked the model to
predict the similarity of pairs of
sentences where the only thing that's
different between the pairs of sentences
is the indicated gender right
all right and so we looked at a hundred
different models that were identically
trained these are based on the vert
natural language processing model if
you're aware of that this is one of the
uh sort of the last generation before we
got to the enormous language models
um right and again these models only
differ by the random seed that was used
at the beginning of optimization for
training right and one way that you can
sort of evaluate how much these models
depend on uh on on gendered Signal is to
look at the Delta and the similarity
between those sentences that I just
showed you and how that Delta
corresponds to the percentage of people
in that occupation who identify as
female but according to the Bureau of
Labor Statistics and so in this plot
here what we'll see is that a larger
slope in this plot corresponds to a
model that depends more on gendered
signals
right
and so these are two different models
again that differ only by the random
seed one of them depends
a huge amount on the gendered
information one of them depends very
little on that gendered information
Beyond just sort of an intercept right
and so these are two different models
that are processing these sentences in
completely different ways
right so
um
again this is not a question necessarily
of there being a ground truth in this
particular case however what it does
point to is that there are many
different ways that you can obtain a
model that predicts very well in this
context
right and
if you were to throw this right if you
were to even treat this as an
interpretation method right you would
get very different interpretations
from
two different models that were trained
on exactly the same data right same
architecture and so this seems to be a
very unstable way to try to gain
insights into how a particular system
works
and one thing that we found here was
looking across a bunch of different
cases where we're using uh
neural network models for these right
linear models for these just sort of
small theoretical models here right we
were able to replicate this phenomenon
across a bunch of different cases
um right where we had models that had
again uh equivalent
prediction performance on held out IID
data but ended up processing inputs very
differently
right so this is a case where we can't
just rely on interpreting the model
itself in order to gain insights about
what we think is a more stable
underlying system
right this is this is a case where even
just prediction alone is not going to
give us some stable signals to interpret
it all can you define what you mean by
stable
yes
um so the question is can I define what
I mean by stable
um so in in this case what I mean is
that we should expect the conclusions
that we would get from an analysis like
this one
right to be
um
indistinguishable right if the only
thing that's changing between these
things is something that we think is
completely irrelevant
but that's the question of the data if
the data has unique solution then any
good predictor will give you something
very similar if the data has different
optimizing Solutions then you'll have
instability but it says nothing to to do
about the process it has to do with the
nature of the data does it have a single
Optimum or it has many Optima which are
different yeah so the comment here is
that this is more of a uh this is more
of a property of the data and in
particular whether there are multiple
Optima or just a single Optimum right
and uh that it has nothing to do with
the underlying process so I I agree with
you yeah right but I'm I think that the
right the issue here is that if we think
that there is an underlying system that
we'd like to understand right the entire
pipeline that I'm talking about here
right from the choice of training data
to the particular model that you're
training and the optimization and
validation strategy that you're using to
get something to predicts well right is
not giving you a single picture of the
underlying system and yes I agree that
this is this is something that is
relatively obvious but if we want to
right the the sort of underlying Point
here that I'm trying to make right and
uh the reason that I brought up the
identification question at all right is
to say that if we want our
interpretations to actually teach us
something about an underlying system
then we need to set up the entire
pipeline world right it's not just the
questions maybe what you want to learn
about nature is that it has different
options and that's a property of nature
why these guys why Why obscued by saying
I want the model with a single option so
Nature has different Optima and it's
interesting to find out and not just
find a method that will
throw it away because I believe in the
religion of the singularity
okay the the comment is that maybe
Nature has multiple apps about it and we
shouldn't dogmatically throw away cases
where there are multiple optimizes
um and I
I think there is right in in many of
these cases right we have a sense that
there is a
uh that there is a generating mechanism
that we're trying to learn about
underlying this particular data
generation process
right and so
um
in like I actually think that it makes a
lot of sense to report say a set of
hypotheses that are uh that are
compatible with the data that have been
generated in fact I have a couple of
slides about that later on here
um
but uh yeah I mean I think it may be
worth coming back to uh in in what cases
we
expect this kind of multiplicity of
solutions to actually point to something
substantive versus whether we think the
multiplicity of solutions actually
points to
a weakness in the uh in the analysis
strategy yeah and we we could certainly
talk about that during the panel I think
train on the same data different models
they're not different models they
identical architecture identical
training data
right so I guess like as far as
considering what if what if we saw
that they were the same
and it's like in some sense you
like your your concerned
you're concerned that this is something
that maybe if you find undesirable
doesn't seem to really hinge upon this
question of whether or not you find
differences across the seeds right like
you know I think uh so I think we could
find lots of like in this case you're
looking at something very strange
because we're not looking at actually
the thing the model is being evaluated
on you know in this intermediate thing
which is like similarity metric included
on the representations which doesn't
necessarily it's like only who knows
what way to what the model is actually
trained for if we looked at something
like
you know the actual predictions of the
model I think we would very well find
that they both exhibit the same bias
that they tend to associate certain
occupations or certain gender and we
find this to be problematic for a reason
that's tied to the the sort of like
moral character of like acting on such
inferences in certain settings but does
not you know like I feel like the
concern that we have about that maybe
stands outside the question of under
specification in some way like we would
still find this bothersome but not for
the reasons that have to do it on a
specification is that right or not right
um so yeah I I think okay so the the
comment was that uh it seems like
they're sort of separate issues here one
of them being the fact that these lines
are different and another one being that
uh you know we we actually see uh some
kind of pattern here in terms of uh like
uh
you know Reliance on on gender
information that we maybe think
shouldn't be there for sort of moral
reasons
um yes I think that that is that is true
the the thing is though that I think in
in a lot of cases
right the uh like we would only sort of
produce one of these models right and
then we would say something like
a property of this pipeline is that it
produces gender bias that looks like
this
right and that would sort of be the the
end right to say that the data that that
that was generated for the stress test
here has the property that when you run
it through this pipeline it has a line
that looks like this what I'm trying to
say here is that if we are not more
careful about how we actually Define the
entire pipeline right there's not just
one property that comes out of this
right this this entire question is sort
of ill-formed because there are many
different answers to it
um right and so I'm I think what I'm
trying to do is to sort of turn the
focus from say this particular
interpretation that we constructed of
this model
to these surrounding questions about uh
you know whether this entire pipeline
could give us a single answer to begin
with right like whether we could expect
the interpretation to actually give us a
straight answer about the question that
we're asking
I mean I I think that we sort of over uh
we have more time than necessary for the
the panel but we could also save some of
these questions for the panel if we
wanted to that's a good idea
absolutely yeah
um sorry I know I skipped over you a
budget
um yeah so I think this is an exception
of the question Zach asked how do you
really utilize this study because in
this example we
right so we could in this case sort of
tease apart the effects of focusing on a
serious feature very well because being
temporary that this is a potential
problem right in the general case how do
we get to these kind of stable features
and
um table is defined like transferable
features like it's sort of defined in
place yeah yeah
um so I to quickly summarize uh the
question was this this particular study
here we actually sort of knew that
there's a spurious feature right and
there's a question about how we would
try to pull out a spurious feature in a
more General context where we don't
actually know what what it is that we're
looking for and like part of my point
here is that if you didn't know that
gender was a spurious feature here right
but you saw this line you would come
away with very different conclusions
from if you saw this line right and it's
because as again these models that sort
of satisfy all of these same constraints
about uh just producing a model that
fits the data well
right they they make no distinction
right this pipeline makes no distinction
between these two lines and the two
conclusions that you would that you
would come to here so I think it's a
very interesting question there about
how we think about pulling out spurious
correlations and all that
um I think it's a little bit orthogonal
to the point here although I'd be happy
to talk more about that
later all right I'm going to try to sort
of blast through the end of this because
I have very similar sort of uh points
that I'm going to try to make maybe a
little bit more clearly
um in in the next set of slides so just
just one thing to point out here right
is that
um right this issue of having models
whose predictions are under constrained
in certain parts of the data space is
actually something where when we're
working on causal inference problems and
trying to learn about causal effects uh
that are defined in terms of say like do
interventions right one of the core
assumptions that we make is uh is about
overlap or positivity right and this
assumption is something that allows us
to say that um everywhere that we need
to make a prediction right we expect at
least asymptotically for there to be
enough data there such that the
prediction is going to be well defined
and this is a case where like under
specification is one case where I think
they're sort of not enough data there to
actually uh constrain the prediction
that you're going to be making
all right so another case right that
comes up in causal inference and again
this is something that I'm trying to
give these as examples of things that uh
are known problems when we try to do
causal inference and are thus sort of
dealt with by making contextual
assumptions right saying that we're
going to satisfy some criteria that that
assume these things away
right is a case where there's an
unobservement founder that you don't
actually observe in your data and you
can't adjust for using some of the the
methods that I talked about before right
so in this case here we don't know
whether the correlation between a and Y
comes through a common cause or whether
it comes through uh this direct causal
relationship between a and Y right so
from observed data alone we can't
disentangle these two things
right and so one thing that you can do
is say well if I just fix what the
distribution The Joint distribution of Y
and a my observables are then I can tell
a bunch of different stories about how
this unobserved variable is related to
my uh to my causes and My outcome and
those are going to give me a bunch of
different theories about the causal
process the underlying underlying causal
process here right that are all
equivalently supported by the observed
data
right and so there's a sort of cottage
industry of methods called sensitivity
analysis that basically do this they'll
parameterize the relationship between
the unobserved confounder the uh the
causes and the outcomes right and
they'll produce plots like this that
sort of show you at different levels of
the relationship between the unserved
confounder and treatment the unobserved
confounder and outcome different values
of the quantity that you're interested
in right
um and so these all correspond to sort
of causal hypotheses that are
equivalently supported by the observed
data and so again this is uh the kind of
situation right where
uh it is necessary if you want to get a
straight answer about what's going on in
the natural world
on to uh make an additional contextual
assumption that you are going to try to
satisfy with the uh design of your study
and the pipeline that you're going to
use to try to model the world right
and so in causal inference the thing
that we do is we assume something like
unconfoundedness right informally we
assume that all the confounders are
observed and can be adjusted for or
alternatively right if we don't think
that we have enough information to
actually nail down a causal hypothesis
we can do a sensitivity analysis
great okay so just coming back to this I
think the the key thing that I wanted to
say right was that if we want our
interpretations like if we want to think
about interpretability as something that
gives us a straight answer about the
natural world
um it seems like it's necessary and
we've talked about this a bunch before
to uh provide some contextual
assumptions right that actually ground
our model in uh in the natural world
right that sort of establish a mapping
between the things that we want to learn
in nature and the data that we're
modeling
this is not something that I've uh that
I've personally seen in uh work that
proposes different interpretability
methods but it seems like there sort of
needs to be this framework built around
the entire modeling process right in
order for interpretations to actually
teach us something about the natural
world
um so I'd love to talk about more of
this stuff if there's stuff that I
haven't seen in literature or something
uh that would be great so thanks so much
[Applause]
thank you so much